(soft music)
- [Reporter] Look at this kitchen counter.
So clean.
This one?
Not so much.
The first may seem safer,
but both could be
harboring the coronavirus.
- There's a common misconception
between cleaning and disinfection.
- [Reporter] That's Bryan Warcholek.
He's the general manager of
the COVID-19 response team
for Aftermath Services.
- Anybody without training can clean.
It's gonna be everything
that you can't see
that needs to be disinfected.
- [Reporter] He's gonna
explain how to properly
and safely disinfect your home.
- At a bare minimum, you're
gonna want to have gloves
and, potentially, a
paper mask and goggles.
When you're preparing to disinfect,
you're going to need towels,
whether it be paper towels
or dropcloths or whatever that you have
to wipe the surfaces.
You're gonna need to have
some sort of disinfectant.
You're gonna want to assure
that that disinfectant
is on the EPA's list
that specifically kills the coronavirus.
If you can't find any
disinfectants in the store,
you can make a bleach mixture at home
using 1/3 cup to a gallon of water
or four teaspoons to a quart of water.
When working with bleach,
make sure that you're in
a well-ventilated area
and wearing the proper PPE.
(bell dings)
Step one is going to be
identifying the surfaces
that you're going to disinfect.
So you're gonna pick out
your high touch areas,
whether it be your light
switches, faucets, doorknobs,
things that you know for
sure you're gonna touch,
things that you wouldn't even think twice
when you touch it on normal circumstances
but you're gonna have to
really have heightened senses
of what you touch on a regular basis.
And even outside of the home,
there are certain surfaces
that you probably are
gonna want to disinfect,
your exterior doorknobs, your mailbox,
the handle to your
vehicle, things like that
that you wouldn't normally
think would be high touch
but you do touch them every day.
(bell dings)
Step two is going to be
preparing the surface
for disinfection.
Your gonna do this by using the towels
that you have available with warm water
or warm, soapy water.
You're gonna wipe down all of the surfaces
that you are going to be disinfecting
to remove any surface
gross filth, dust, debris,
whatever it may be.
Now that you've cleaned the
surfaces, they may appear clean,
they may appear that
there's nothing there,
but it's gonna be what you can't see,
the microscopic bacteria, microbials,
viruses that you can't
see that you have now
prepared the surface for
the disinfectant to work on.
(bell dings)
Step three is disinfect your surfaces.
Now that your surfaces
are ready to disinfect,
you're gonna want to don whatever PPE
that you do have available.
Gloves, masks, and goggles
would be best for starters,
then once you have on
your PPE and you're ready,
you're gonna apply the disinfectant.
If your disinfectant is
coming through a spray bottle,
you're gonna want to mist
it onto the surfaces.
You're gonna want to make sure
that you are not saturating
or leaving pooling behind.
You need the disinfectant to do its job
and it needs to be misted onto the surface
and it has to stay damp
for the allotted cure time.
If you have a wipe, you're
gonna want to remove it
from the container that it's
in, apply it to the surfaces
by wiping back and forth
across the surface.
You're gonna use that wipe
until it starts to dry up
and it's no longer leaving
any disinfectant behind.
(bell dings)
Step four is wait.
You're waiting for the
disinfectant to do its job.
It varies by disinfectant.
Some can be as soon as instantaneous
and some can be up to 10 minutes.
Always refer to the label
that's on the bottle
or refer to the CDC's recommendations
for how long to let it cure.
(bell dings)
Step five is going to be
to rinse the surfaces.
The best practice is gonna be
to fold a kitchen towel into fourths,
damp that towel, and
then use one side of it
to do one sweeping motion, open it up,
use the other side of it.
That way, you're getting
the most out of that towel
when you're rinsing the surfaces.
It's best practice that each swipe
is about five to eight feet.
If you're using paper towels,
one towel folded in half
should cover the same five to eight feet.
After this, the surfaces will air dry
or you can dry 'em by hand
with another paper towel
or another towel you have available.
(bell dings)
After you are completely
done with disinfecting,
you should probably repeat the process
depending on your lifestyle.
If you're in and out of the
home several times a day,
you're going to want to
do it several times a day.
If you work from home,
twice, three times a day should suffice.
It should be in the morning,
afternoon, and evening though.
I think when people are getting
comfortable in their homes,
they're getting complacent
and they're not thinking
that they have to disinfect surfaces,
but you truly don't
understand who has the virus
'cause they could be asymptomatic
so you do need to take
the extra precaution,
regardless of what the
surface may look like already.
(soft music)